le lieu du crime est sinistre et isolé
on y accède par un chemin long et
escarpé jonché de gravats en contrebas
de la rue des grandes saules à
Argenteuil
[Musique]
sous le pont de l'autoroute A15 qu'on
appelle viaduc de Gennevilliers le bruit
de fond du trafic est incessant et
étouffrait le moindre cri
un endroit idéal pour tendre un
guet-apens
[Musique]
c'est ici tout au bout du chemin au pied
de la gigantesque pile en béton du
viaduc kalysha 14 ans a été roué de coup
par deux de ses camarades de classe puis
jeter encore vivante dans la Seine
5 mètres plus bas
[Musique]
comment une simple intrigante adolescent
peut-être dégénérer à ce point et
pourquoi ces jeunes sont-ils passés à
l'acte avec une telle violence je
m'appelle brune Audrey et je reviens
pour Le Figaro sur ce terrible crime
d'ado qu'elle a fait à l'Isha avec
Guillaume point journaliste fait divers
au Figaro et le docteur Emmanuel
Sautereau pédopsychiatre responsable
d'une unité médicale pour adolescent au
CHS d'Auxerre et expert près la Cour
d'appel de Paris
[Musique]
dans cette histoire il y a donc trois
personnages principaux allisha 14 ans la
victime et ses deux bourreaux qui ont
tous les deux 15 ans leur âge ne nous
permet pas de dévoiler leur identité
alors nous les appellerons Thomas et
Cindy Alisha vivait dans un quartier
résidentiel calme situé sur les hauteurs
d'Argenteuil avec ses parents
et ses trois frères et sœurs
à l'entrée du pavillon familial un
drapeau français côtoie un écusson du
Pakistan pays d'origine de ses parents
Guillaume point a suivi cette affaire
pour Le Figaro est-ce qu'on peut dire
sur la victime c'est qu'elle vivait dans
une famille en apparence unie une ado
normal en quelque sorte sans histoire
c'est une jeune fille que ses proches
décrivent vraiment comme une jeune fille
simple elle aime dessiner elle aime
faire des promenades c'est une jeune
fille voilà qui le week-end aime passer
du temps avec sa famille elle consacre
ses week-ends
[Musique]
le contexte familial est un peu
différent Thomas vit seul avec sa mère
et son père est décédé il y a quelques
années or Thomas c'est un ado qui a un
côté assez geek en fait il est décrit
comme assez réservé comme passant
beaucoup de temps dans sa chambre devant
son ordinateur il est décrit comme assez
timide comme même un petit peu peureux
et féminé mais c'est aussi quelqu'un qui
a un côté un petit peu clown c'est
proche et son entourage disent qu'il
aime bien faire des blagues donc il a un
peu cette double facette à la fois
timide et en même temps un côté un peu
un peu clown
[Musique]
cindy est la seule qui n'habite pas à
Argenteuil elle vient d'une commune
limitrophe elle vient d'Herblay et sa
personnalité est un petit peu plus
complexe pour ne pas dire perturber on a
notamment discuté avec un ancien parents
d'élèves de son ancien collège et selon
ce père de famille donc elle avait été
exclu de son ancien collège pour des
histoires de bagarres et elle avait
aussi visiblement tendance à inventer
des voilà inventer des histoires à
raconter tout un tas de choses
complètement fausses
les trois adolescents se rencontrent à
la rentrée de septembre 2020 ils sont
tous les trois dans la même classe de
troisième B du lycée privé professionnel
cognac g d'argentuil en début d'année
alicha et Thomas auraient eu une brève
relation voilà une petite relation entre
adolescents qui aurait duré très peu de
temps seulement quelques jours et
ensuite quelques semaines plus tard
Thomas et Cindy se sont mis en couple
thomas était très amoureux de Cindy
comme l'a expliqué son son avocat Maître
Franck Berton Cindy c'était sa première
relation sexuelle donc voilà il y avait
vraiment un attachement entre les deux
au contact de Cindy le jeune Thomas
change lui qui ne sortait quasiment
jamais de sa chambre passe de plus en
plus de temps dehors et de moins en
moins de temps derrière son ordinateur
pour être au contact de sa petite amie
Cindy en fait ce que disent les proches
de Thomas et notamment sa maman c'est
que c'est que le jeune homme en fait a
complètement changé sous l'influence de
sa de sa nouvelle petite amie Cindy tous
ces proches vraiment décrivent une
relation un peu de manipulation voilà il
raconte que il était obligé de porter le
sac de sa petite amie que parfois lui
donner des coups de pied ou des petites
tapes derrière la nuque Cindy alicha
elle sont aussi amies en tout cas elle
le reste tout l'automne et elle se
fréquente aussi en dehors des cours en
dehors de l'école et c'est à partir de
janvier 2021 que les relations entre les
trois protagonistes vont se muer en
haine
pour des raisons encore assez obscures
alicha devient la cible du couple Thomas
Cindy
au mois de février des photos en
sous-vêtement d'alicha sont postés sur
le groupe snapchat de l'ensemble de la
classe des trois camarades Thomas et
Cindy seraient à l'oeuvre et puis le 1er
mars une violente bagarre éclate au sein
de l'établissement entre Cindy et Aïcha
pour ses faits Thomas et Cindy sont
d'ailleurs exclus de l'établissement et
sont convoqués pour un conseil de
discipline le 9 mars prochain mais ce
conseil n'aura pas lieu car la veille
Thomas et Cindy tande un guet-apens
mortel à Alisha
alors le ce qui se passe le 8 mars c'est
que Cindy donne rendez-vous à LISHA à la
gare d'Argenteuil ensuite les deux
jeunes filles se rendent à pied sur les
sur les quais de scènes en fait où elles
ont où elles ont l'habitude de
visiblement de discuter de se retrouver
etc et là arriver sur place donc il y a
Thomas qui était caché derrière un
pilier qui qui surgit nulle part et donc
là en fait il commence à faire une
balayette à l'Isha donc qui se retrouve
au sol
ensuite la jeune fille est rouée de coup
voilà elle prend des coups dans le dos
elle prend des coups sur le visage etc
et malgré ces gémissements en fait ils
décident de la jeter vivante en
contrebas dans la scène l'autopsie
d'alicha révèle de très importants
hématomes au niveau du crâne des
contusions à l'oeil et de nombreux
ecchymoses dans le dos l'autopsie
conclut à une mort par noyade
mais alors pourquoi ont-ils tué à l'Isha
selon le procureur de la République de
Pontoise en charge de l'affaire à
l'époque
Eric corbeau les deux suspects n'ont pas
fait part d'un remord immédiat lors de
leur garde à vue il finissent par
reconnaître les faits même si le mobile
reste flou j'ai expliqué qu'il y avait
donc cette rivalité qu'il y avait
effectivement ce vol de de photos que il
y avait eu une bagarre entre les deux
jeunes filles le jeune homme se
plaignant également que la victime
aurait parlé mal de son père voit aurait
raconté des mensonges sur leur relation
donc on est sur voilà des
futilités de ce de ce type là qui aurait
d'après notamment les SMS
justifier l'envie de voilà de faire
quelque chose en direction de la victime
m'empêche de dormir
je n'arrive plus à dormir
ce crime d'ado soulève une grande
émotion à travers le pays et les
politiques sont saisis pour dénoncer le
harcèlement scolaire on aperçoit Valérie
Pécresse lors de la Marche Blanche en
hommage à la jeune victime et le
porte-parole du gouvernement de l'époque
Gabriel Attal évoque même ce fait divers
lors d'un compte-rendu du conseil des
ministres ce qui est arrivé à cette
jeune fille est absolument terrible et
ignoble
c'est une jeune fille qui a été emportée
par le harcèlement qui a été emporté par
une spirale infernale qui a conduit à ce
drame et je veux dire à sa famille à
tous ceux qui les menaient notre
solidarité et notre émotion face à cette
situation absolument tragique
[Musique]
mais au-delà de l'émotion légitime
autour d'une telle affaire j'ai voulu
savoir ce que ce crime d'ado révélait de
notre jeunesse j'ai donc posé la
question au pédopsychiatre Emmanuel
Sautereau il dirige une antenne
spécialisée pour adolescent au CHS
d'Auxerre et est également expert près
de la cour d'appel de Paris
[Musique]
un processus
exceptionnel mais une exprime bien quand
même les phénomènes de violence extrême
on peut retrouver chez les adolescents
et cette
violence on a retrouvé alors de manière
dirigée mais aussi beaucoup
autodérision c'est beaucoup
d'adolescents et on se rend compte que
si vous voulez
aujourd'hui les adolescents ne vont pas
aussi bien qu'il pouvait aller 10-15 ans
et à 15 ans dit ils ont trouvé que de
manière assez marginale les
problématiques des adolescents
aujourd'hui avec la majorité de nos de
nos collègues ou on constate cette
augmentation des problématiques
adolescentes avec une expression
effectivement parfois dans la violence
le retrait qu'est-ce qui fait qu'un ado
passe à l'acte avec une telle violence
alors bien souvent si vous voulez on se
rencontre que que très tôt les
les enfants
intérioristes difficilement un certain
nombre d'interdits avec une autorité qui
est souvent mise à mal ou pas reconnu ou
pas exercer
avec aussi une
mise en avant d'une position quasi toute
puissante de
de l'enfant où on peut plus interdire à
l'enfant ou limiter
l'enfant dans ses voyez dans ses envies
dans ces
dans ces désirs mais parfois sans limite
et l'enfant perd un petit peu cette
cette capacité à
construire un intérieur
qui lui permet de différer
une exigence de de repousser un petit
peu de sortir un peu comportement de
toute puissance parce que la toute
puissance amène à un monde sans limite
et sans limite
tout est permis et c'est ces jeunes
souvent ne retrouvent des limites que
lorsqu'ils n'ont pas la société ils vont
parfait marquer sur leur propre corps
avec ces marques de scarification ou il
nous disent mais quand je me blesse je
sens que j'ai une limite et que mon
corps existe et il y a souvent si vous
voulez je pense que ces mouvements là
traduisent bien les failles des
limitataires que ne peuvent que nous pas
construire les jeunes enfants et après
les adolescents
alors bon classiquement dans les
familles enfin traditionnellement
l'autorité était
juste évolue au père dans cette fonction
après qui peut devenir un modèle
d'identification
pour les enfants ici là dans ce cas je
crois qu'il y avait effectivement une
situation d'un jeune qui n'avait pas
d'image fraternelle très structurant
donc dans un lien peut-être serré
à sa mère avec peut-être aussi
culpabilité d'une mère de ne pas vouloir
réprimander son enfant et il y a bien
souvent une confusion entre une autorité
qui protège et une autorité qui interdit
et on les voit souvent que parfois le
côté interditeur et rester de
restrictions de la
de la démarche d'autorité alors qu'elle
est fondamentalement protectrice du
sujet tant vis-à-vis de la société que
pour son fonctionnement
interne et ces processus si vous voulez
de
de pouvoir réfréner de mettre en attente
vient du sujet et souvent défaillant
est-ce qu'il est un peu l'ouverture
assez
assez comportements sans limite il y a
une telle rage qui qu'aucune élaboration
et aucun
aucune retenue souvent n'est possible
c'est la fin de cet épisode si ça vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à le partager un grand
merci aux collègues qui m'ont aidé Kevin
et butterne pour le motion design Riad
Bekir et Julien Leclerc pour la
réalisation à bientôt
[Musique]